foreign
I think to a certain degree it's it
depends on who you're asking right I'm
asking you asking me for me
you can't escape
yeah like I said a girl who just sleeps
around if she's not interested in making
a connection with a guy and she's got
the mindset that she can be like men
where she can have sex without having
any kind of emotional attachment to the
guy
you know then and she's not concerned
about racking up guy off the guy off the
guy and to me I consider that to be
holish Behavior it's not behavior of a
woman who's really interested in the
long term she's more interested in the
short term do you ask girls what their
body counters no no
do you no
no I never have I don't feel like that's
a good question to ask because if you do
it's always going to come back with a
negative response or a lie but Paul the
reason I don't ask is because we don't
have to ask so there's certain questions
you can ask and you know the body count
there's certain reactions that women
with high body counts give off
um and a certain energy so we can just
already just we we know so I want to ask
the girls do you feel like because as as
women I think we know a little bit more
behind the scenes than men typically do
do you think that men can tell a girl's
body count based off of like your
friends and your friends friends
extend yeah to a certain extent what
extent in a way where
um there's a lot of girls that I knew
back in the day that had no intention of
sleeping around but maybe they might
have been with friends that have
possibly done all of that and then it
makes it seem as if like you do that
[ __ ] too sorry am I allowed to it sorry
do you do that stuff too so
it kind of gets looked upon like you're
you're one of them so no but like at the
same time birds have ever do flock
together they do but why can't it
doesn't necessarily have to mean that
the girl's doing the same thing they
simply mean it but sometimes you have to
carry yourself with the kind of people
that you want to be like I don't know
how to say it but
so if you're with the hoes you're at
home so when you when the police pulls
over your car if he pulls off your car
when three people in the car I have
known to for drugs you're gonna get
searched as well that's because you're a
couple of three people that known for
drugs
um you know a lot of times in your area
there can be one good boy you know I
mean and he has some friends but just
because their friends you'll stay
together and you and your mom might say
to you or stop hanging around those
friends stop hanging around those
friends
um because they're not like you but you
hang around with your friends because
they're your friends whenever you get
stopped or whatever happens you're gonna
be
um
um they're gonna treat the same and
that's because a lot of the times mud
sticks so if you don't want to be known
as a hoe or or if you don't want people
to treat you like treat you like one
then if you're hanging around with girls
at a lot of holes then it makes it a lot
harder for you to be the one that's
actually different you know I'm trying
to say to you so it doesn't mean you're
a whole if you hang around with hoes
like there's always there can always be
one good girl that Jeremy's a good girl
but by a rule of thumb you might not you
you might not want to hang around people
which don't have the same type of
Interest or activity activities you you
that's me personally what are you doing
when when they all go out and they're
upstairs in the room with random what
are you doing you're downstairs playing
Solitaire I was about to say play
Nintendo Wii bro sometimes you're just
minding your business and maybe when it
comes to like having sex with boys that
might not be the same topics that I
might not be into but like behind closed
doors when we're not talking about boys
and we're not talking about sex they are
so like typical
topics that are like yeah this is why
I'm your friend so whenever a girl gets
a man most girls have always got one
whole friend most girls always got one
whole friend and they know their hoe and
no and they don't like to admit their
whole but they're their whole friend and
whenever they get whenever they get a
new man a lot of the times the man will
clot this whole friend and he'll say
certain things and you and you know I
mean he'll be like oh that your friend
that your friend he's not trying to call
your friend a whole but you don't want
to call your friend a hoe to your man
but we all know we all know and you know
as a guy we always have to deal with
that and it and a lot of times those
friends don't tend to hang around for
too long after that person gets a man or
whatever is because
your whole life doesn't represent what
they live anymore and I'm trying to say
to you versus she wants to be going out
and doing certain things and now you've
got a man and maybe your man don't want
you to be there because she's rightly
single she can go out and you know
interact with other men and be taken to
tables but if you're out with her now
you automatically put yourself in a
predicament where other men can now
start speaking to you and if she is a
whole and known for being a hole out in
the club every single guy in there is
going to see you as a whole and there's
nothing worth being seen as something
that you're not and people treat you
like that and your man hearing that all
your girls out with some hole in a
nightclub
do you guys do you think you guys think
it's appropriate to go out in a
relationship yeah why not is it is that
a bad thing though
when you're out well what are you going
out for whoa you got you gotta I can't
let my hair down for five minutes on my
goals it's like why are you fishing if
you don't want to fish
oh so would you go out for yourself to
have a good time yeah is that no
seriously is that a thing no you I mean
that's just I'm just telling you guys
how men view it like I'm just being
honest like I listen to guys talk all
the time like if you're going out all
the time it's like
you can you can say like I I'm I'm not a
hoe right but if all your friends are
hoes you're going out to the club all
the time it's like you're dressing like
a hoe acting like a hoe it's like how
are they supposed to think you're not a
hoe for what my truck
I don't call it but I think it's like
it's same thing with a guy if he if he
hangs around a bunch of friends that
I'll cheat
if he looks like he's cheating if he's
acting like he's cheating you're gonna
assume he's cheering yeah and you'll
fall in love because women love being
cheated on well then if you don't trust
your partner that is a problem in itself
okay it does have a big trust is a big
thing a big thing so
how does a relationship work without it
I mean you yeah but like why would you
put yourself in that situation yeah like
I just think if you truly respect the
guy you're with like you wouldn't want
to do anything that would make him look
bad and it makes a guy like like as a
woman you want to make your man look
good like that's your job and so when
you're dressing like a hoe taking going
out with your whole friends to the club
where they're all hooking up with guys
and you're saying oh they're all doing
it but not me I promise I won't flirt
with anyone but I'm going to the one
place where we're bound to get hit on
it's like you you look bad as a girl and
you make him look bad so we're typically
we're talking about girls that have hoe
friends and when they go out not just
girls in general we're just talking
about the hoes when they go what else
are you going to a club for
I just find myself yeah I've I've
literally never heard
everybody I guess has different points
of views while men and men have
different points of views when it comes
to women but that that is very new for
me I must say
I I think
if it's new for you then I always ask
myself like what types of men have you
have you had like what types of
boyfriends that's why I said I've been
single for 10 years because I don't go
out okay so let me I don't do that so
so you haven't been single for 10 years
I have been single we had sex in the
last 10 years I have that doesn't
necessarily mean I was in a relationship
okay so so but you see this is the thing
that women do so what you was initially
I was thinking oh for 10 years she's out
I've been out the game she is you know
no you haven't because you've been
having sex like so so you've been in the
game enough to be able to have sex but
not in the game or not not enough to
secure a man a proper relationship so
you know how to have sex this and this
is what I said women can have sex any
day of the any day of the of the week
and you look to me a little bit funny
you've been abeing the last 10 years you
cannot you cannot keep a man okay cool
wait I can't keep a man because I
haven't been in a relationship for 10
years because I've had relationships
well well yeah well it just it just
means that the men you want don't want
you there's one for six yeah like that's
you guys understanding then I'll take it
oh no no I want to explain okay so put
it this way I have dated men and they
have not given me or made me feel like I
was safe enough to be in a relationship
let's just play that for number one
number two yes I have had sex that
doesn't necessarily mean I have to I've
had sex with multiple men it doesn't
necessarily mean that the person that
I've had sex with I want to be in a
relationship with them that's can that
can still be my choice and that can
still be okay of course so when I say
it's okay for me to be single for 10
years without a relationship I think
that's very normal so you I'm just
you're right it's normal nowadays like
nowadays it's not uncommon but it's
because modern women are side chicks I'm
not a scientist you said that because
okay it's it's this is my relationship
I'm not even saying this like to be me
it's just this is how relationships
start nowadays they start like how many
times have you heard of a situationship
so and it seems like you've been in a
situation I haven't you okay then what
else would you call sleeping with
someone
friends the benefits is that noise a
situation okay so and so so if you're in
a Friends with Benefits situation that's
uncommitted so what else is he doing
you're side chick I'm not a side jerk I
feel like a side chick has been to
somebody's in a relationship with
somebody and then they're doing
something with somebody on the side okay
now the side chick is when you're one of
many chicks as a man as a man as a man
this this thing of where you women have
to believe there has to be remain in
order for me to be a side chick it's not
it's a it's a crazy phenomenon if you're
one of a selection you're a side chick
that's it stop thinking that he has to
have a main one where he looks after
you're just one of many I'm not but I
understand what you're saying but I'm
not okay okay if you were sleeping with
a man and he wasn't your he wasn't your
boyfriend he wasn't your husband yeah
yeah and he wasn't and he wasn't and he
wasn't yes he's single and so were you
so therefore you just you was a side to
ingrown things honestly see what you're
trying to do you're trying to move the
goal post you keep trying to change it
now we're doing good yes it's grown
things but those grown things still
amount to you being a side chick and not
his main woman and that's your opinion
and that's okay
and that's okay this is the majority of
women in this day and age I'd say this
started from can I ask you over there
yeah I'm not saying it's not I'm not
saying it's uncommon yeah it's like
that's how I mean that's how most
relationships start when I ask people
like it usually starts as a
situationship most women start as side
chicks in the west I will say in the
west and then a lot of the time they put
pressure on the guide to get into a
relationship
yeah but we can see in case you don't
know this is this is a phrase that
people say Okay
um women control sex men control access
to relationships so unless you're gonna
get down on one knee and give me a gold
Rolex and ask me to be your husband then
what you have to do is you have to fall
in your femininity along for me to ask
you to be my girlfriend then I'm gonna
be like oh my gosh this girl is better
than all the rest of the women I want to
lock her down I want to go to the
Jewelers and buy a ring and give it to
you so this is a process that needs to
happen and in order for this to happen
you have to understand that process but
the moment you give a guy sex days after
that you've given them everything
already so there's no there's no need
for him to actually make you into his
girl or his wife the need to make into
his girl or his wife is because you
possess something that no other women
have if it's just sex and you give it
away and you're not a virgin to give it
to other men then we don't consider it
as something special and the problem is
a lot if I'm not looking for something
what if I'm not looking that's fine
that's also fine but I think at some
level yeah unless you're saying you
don't want to be you don't know you
don't then at some level you're going to
want something so so a lot of the things
you do in the past can affect the guy
that you actually meet when he meets you
and actually likes you and then he's
like okay cool you run through all of
these guys it affects us not necessarily
I'm talking as many of you know I was
just banned on Tic Tac and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible